there and we've got the one
down in the back here
let's start with five and if you see
okay
first like eight minutes in
for a while
yeah we're to go back
and then so you're going to go over
there
i'll move around
microphone check 10 9
8 7 6 five
four perfect
uh
foreign
sorry
is
all right
oh my god the bonus
praying daycare does not close down due
to the surgery
i
uh
okay
thanks jake
it's amazing
twice
hey
actually
thank you
yes
um
all right
now that's getting down in the weeds
right now considering everything
says
you
uh
good morning everyone as always it's an
honor to
welcome back to the house side our
former colleague here but now
the democratic leader in the senate jeff
schumer
uh malcolm mr leader
words have power when the president
speaks his words
weigh a ton and we've heard some things
lately that are very uh disconcerting
but numbers have eloquence too
yesterday our nation suffered a
horrifying
144 000 new infections
recorded the eighth straight day
of over 100 000
cases being reported more than 65
000 americans are hospitalized with
covid
a few wreck a new record that threatens
to overwhelm
our hospitals and are hospitals in rural
areas
particularly effective the devastating
milestone of 10 million americans
infected has been passed
144 yesterday
eighth day over a hundred sixty five
thousand
people hospitalized with covid 10
million americans
more than 10 million americans affected
and more than 240
000 americans have died
more than 20 million americans are on
unemployment
an american has a 1 million fewer
teachers
than a year ago that's why we keep
saying honor our heroes state and local
government where our teachers
over 90 of their uh budget comes from
nearly 8 million people have fallen into
poverty
and 17 million children in america are
food insecure
this is a red alert an all hands on deck
but it should have been
a long time ago the president
and the republicans in congress have
ignored
by delay distortion
denial deaths have been caused
and what are they doing now continuing
to ignore
in spite of these numbers
that should be so compelling that are an
imperative
for us to act upon this every kind of
uh avoidance of taking responsibility
has been witnessed every every chance
that we had for testing
tracing treatment mask wearing
separation sanitation but science tells
us
to do they have ignored their contempt
for science and they're con this stained
for governance
science says wear mask governance says
let's enforce that science
governance that's not what they're about
that's not what they're about
and what that is is uh they're engaged
in an absurd
circus right now refusing to accept
reality
the republicans are shamefully
pretending a proceeding
without recognizing what our
responsibility
is and making it even harder to address
the massive
health health econo and economic crisis
that we're facing
a delayed
ascertainment of the major harm caused
uh to the presidential transition
is something of another subject right
now
we are talking about addressing
the crisis the pandemic if we do so
scientifically we will be able we will
be able
to open our economy will be able to
open our schools safely we're able to do
so
in a way that recognizes the tragedy
that has befallen us
in our country because of the republican
denial
of science and disdain for governance
so stop the circus and get to work
on what really matters to the american
peace their health
and their economic security with that
i'm pleased to yield to the
distinguished
democratic leader of the senate mr
schumer thank you madam speaker it's
good to be back now good morning
this is a great a moment of great
national challenge
coveted 19 is surging small businesses
are shuttering
families are struggling people continue
to lose jobs
and not gain new ones we just had a
divisive and hard-fought presidential
election
but instead of working but instead of
working to pull the country back
together
so that we can fight our common enemy
covet 19
republicans in congress are spreading
conspiracy theories
denying reality and poisoning the well
of our democracy
the republicans should stop their
shenanigans about an election that
president trump has
already lost and focused their attention
on the immediate issue at hand
providing relief to a country living
through the covet health
and economic crises
when it comes to the election
republicans congressional republicans
don't have the evidence
they don't have the proof they don't
have anything neither does the president
con congressional republicans are
deliberately casting doubt on our
elections
for no other reason but fear of donald
trump
these republicans are all auditioning
for profiles in cowardice
so this morning i have a very simple
message for senate republicans
the election is over it wasn't close
president trump lost joe biden will be
the next president of the united states
kamala harris will be the next vice
president of the united states
senate republicans stop denying reality
stop deliberately and recklessly sowing
doubt about our democratic process
and start focusing on covet
the republican refusal to deal with
reality is hurting our country
in many ways fighting the health crisis
of covet
improving our economy and not
compromising
on national security
it's time to move on and get to work for
the american people
and i want to be very clear with the
american people the election's not in
doubt
this is nothing more than a temper
tantrum by republicans
nothing more than a poetic pathetic
political performance
for for an audience of one
president donald john trump there is
nothing
this is nothing republicans like the
2000 election
when the president-elect when the
presidential election came down to one
state
and the difference between candidates
was only 537 votes
joe biden's victory in the electoral
college has been secured by several
states where tens of thousands of votes
separate the candidates joe biden leaves
and
leads in wisconsin by 20 000
pennsylvania 50 000 michigan 146
000 that's the facts
bidens won nothing republicans or trump
can do will change that
all over the country legal claims by the
president and his republican allies are
being laughed out of court
the new york times called election
officials from both parties in every
state in the country not one not one
reported any evidence of fraud or
irregularities
these frivolous lawsuits have less than
a snowball's chance
in hell of succeeding so let me speak
directly to my republican colleagues in
the senate
once again joe biden has won now move on
and work with us to solve the covet
crisis
let us bring the country together and
get things done
every day as the speaker mentioned
hundreds of thousands are getting sick
thousands are dying we don't have time
for these kinds of games
the american people are waiting for
relief from the covet virus
but republicans refuse to take
comprehensive action
that meets the needs of the country the
heroes act
passed in the house does meet this
moment
it doesn't pick and choose who we're
going to help during the greatest health
and economic crises
in decades it's laser focused on health
care issues that are at the heart of
this pandemic
the heroes act does something that's
vital it strengthens medicaid and
improves access to health care coverage
support for hospitals
at a time when covett is raging health
care money medicaid expansion should be
at the very top of the list
these are the issues we should be
discussing
and debating and the heroes act should
be the starting point
not an emaciated bill that prioritizes
protections for corporations and
considers the needs of american families
as an afterthought
every day that goes by without the
republican party acknowledging and
accepting the results of this election
is another day
americans faith in their wonderful
democracy declines
the longer senate republicans play the
sad game
is the longer they are denying working
families much needed relief
from the covet health and economic
speaker thank you
thank you mr leader uh yes indeed the
heroes act has now for nearly
six months uh been a formula
for crushing the virus for honoring our
heroes
our health care workers our police and
fire our first responders
our teachers our teachers our teachers
our sanitation
transportation food workers people who
make
our economy and our society work
as i said earlier over a million
teachers have already lost their jobs
since last year we need to help our
state and local government they say from
time to time
that that they want to do that but they
we haven't seen that evidence
secondly secondly and this is almost
sinful
crushing the virus is essential
the time of a pandemic instead of
crushing the virus they want to crush
the affordable care act as was
demonstrated
in the supreme court the other day and a
very important point among many others
that the
leader made about the expansion of
medicaid
many seniors this is a middle income uh
benefit
middle income family benefit many many
seniors are in
long-term care well 70
of that long-term care is covered by
medicaid
so yes it is for poor children and poor
families
but an overwhelming amount of it goes to
help middle-class families
have long-term care for their seniors
again again part of the affordable care
act
that not fully implemented by some
states
but again under siege in the court for
the
long the
central issue of it access to affordable
health care preventive care and
protecting the pre-existing condition
benefit which will go right down the
drain with the president's
case in the court so it there's it's
hard to
have what are they thinking or am i
using the word thinking
loosely people are suffering
even before the coronavirus the
affordable care act was essential
not just to the people who got the 20
million more people and that's a
blessing
but the 150 million families who have
private health care uh health insurance
through their
employment and and who have increased
benefits in the bill
as well as medic the medicaid expansion
so
important and the list goes on and on i
won't go through all of the benefits
except
to say that over 75 million people voted
their health
protect the affordable care act crush
the virus
so that we can open up our economy in a
healthy way and it's all doable let me
just name
on a hopeful note the uh
news of the viruses at least one virus
and perhaps another right on the heels
coming out that are very promising
and with high levels of protection
should give people motivation to do
what is necessary to self quarantine to
wear masks etc because just it will only
take a short period of time with many
more people doing that
to reduce the the incidence of the virus
on the right as we go into the path
of a vaccine so again
we should be hopeful but we have to be
careful and we have to
uh honor the science whether it's about
how we
uh how we embrace a vaccine the vaccine
will be the more it is embraced the more
effective it will be
and more effective it will be we need
more of it and call upon the president
uh to use the defense production act to
make sure
that enough is produced so that
everybody
is cared for because unless we're all
protected and that means in the world
not just in our country none of us is
protected so on the health
issue it's just they seem to have a
mental block
to doing the right thing a moral block
for respecting what it's doing to
america's families
as we uh close with martin luther king
who said of all of the inequalities
the inequality of access to health care
is the most inhuman
because people will die any questions on
this sub we're sticking with this
subject today tomorrow i have my
weekly and we can go into other things
listen
is it fair to say your position on the
coronavirus relief
has not changed since before since where
it was before the election is that a
fair characterization
i see your position on where you are in
coronavirus has that not changed since
before the election is that it has been
our position all along to crush the
virus
honor our heroes put money in the
pockets of the american people
but you have the administration saying
well we have just made a light touch on
their language on testing
no 55 of the language which addressed
what we were trying to do for people of
of
communities of color so yeah nowhere
with that same place even more so
early more so with the pandemic because
look at these numbers
look at these numbers look at the
predictions uh from the scientific
community
you know i've come before you over and
over again
uh some weeks ago with frank pallone
saying this is what
we put in the hero's act to crush the
virus
why won't they do it they were in their
herd mentality heard a
immunity mood then and
i would just add one more thing
one more thing given how covet is raging
the number of hospitalizations the
number of deaths
is increased it makes the health care
provisions
in the heroes act even more important
and more vital
that they be included
that said though you know the passage of
the heroes act
it doesn't seem like there's any more of
a path to get to 60 votes
in the senate to get closer there and by
that same score here
it seems as though in the house your
position on the larger bill
you would have a weaker hand to play in
the lane.congress
is that not the case why not i think
that the most compelling
argument of what i said earlier
144 000 people yesterday
and these people are spread all over the
country
the pressure on hospitals
all over the country including in rural
areas
so if the republicans want to be
cold-hearted and say they don't care
or as the president's son said 100 225
000 i think at that time that's no big
number kind of thing
no every single one of those deaths is
important to us we carry those people in
our hearts
and they should be carrying them on
their conscience for what they did not
do
since we passed the bill the heroes act
over a hundred thousand more people have
died
that could have been prevented so
again you've heard me say it a million
times that public sentiment is
everything
and now that the people have expressed
their views
joe biden has won kamala harris will be
the first woman vice president of the
united states
i said to them if we didn't have masks
last week they could see us
beaming with that success
what they have been proposing is very
similar
to what we have in the heroes act and we
just have to fight
to make sure that if the republicans
decide that they don't care about the
health and well-being
about medicaid and what it means to
people in their lives
that the public will know
chad one more thing first
mcconnell is sticking to his emaciated
bill which he's tried twice and didn't
get a republican vote
that's sort of a non-starter and then he
said because we have a vaccine there's
even less need for a bill vaccine makes
greater need for a bill
because it has to be distributed fairly
and equitably and there needs to be
education
that it's healthy and everything else
second
the biggest change since election day is
that donald trump
who is not for helping us in covin who
is against the heroes bill has lost
that was an overwhelming referendum by
the american people
so yes we think there has been change it
should move things in our direction
we're willing to sit down and talk they
haven't wanted to talk they seem to have
stuck
to their position
that what joe biden got gotten this
election
was a mandate a mandate to address the
challenges that our country faces
as well as to have a positive initiative
on how to grow the economy
in a fair way and in order to do that
we must address the covert the pandemic
this election was more maybe more a
referendum on who can handle covidwell
than anything else the donald trump
approach was repudiated the joe biden
approach was embraced
and that's why we think there's a better
chance to get a bill in the lame duck
if only the republicans would stop
embracing the
ridiculous shenanigans that trump is
forcing them to do
that this uh you know in in the election
and focus on what people need
speaker pelosi in 2000 democrat al gore
was allowed to press his legal challenge
against george w bush in florida for
37 days do you think the same type of
patient should be afforded to president
trump in his legal challenges
let me say what dick cheney said at the
time
uh in 2000 the delayed ascertainment
caused many difficulties the bush
administration without spoke was
outspoken about the
uh the about what was happening in the
country and as the leader said
this is a completely different situation
we're talking about one
state bp dick cheney said on november
27th we will pay a heavy price for
delays in planning and assembly of the
next administration
and i don't think i don't think this the
biden being having been
uh of the uh vice president of the
united states the chairman of the
foreign affairs committee the chairman
of the judiciary committee
he knows the territory so he's going to
be just fine
in the transition he's going to be just
fine in the transition
it's most unfortunate that the
republicans have decided
that they will not respect the will of
the people and let me just say
it's like the house is burning down and
they just refuse to throw water
on it but we are on a path now
this the vaccines which were coming out
of the private sector actually the uh
pfizer vaccine coming out of the private
sector show great promise
and that promise is to say all the more
reason
to wear a mask self isolate
a self yeah
quarantine and and uh let us work
together to get this
done i am i can't this is like a gift
from god
to come down and help cure
cure this pandemic not cure just uh
prevent it from being spread
and with a vaccine to inoculate against
it
and as we inoculate against the vaccine
against the virus
we also should be inoculating against
all the injustices
that are contained in how it is being
spread and the rest
thank you all very much thank you
i think